les chéris vous le savez entre gilles et
fatou à l'ambiance est plutôt tendue
fatou c'est la compagne de gilles depuis
x années et c'est une affaire qui nous
touche tous voient aussi tous les gens
actuellement m'arrêtent dans la rue me
dise où on en est de gilles et de fat
ont alors qu'ils s'étaient ce matin vous
avez rendez vous pour le comptable ou
c'est demain c'était aujourd'hui mais
vous qu'aujourd'hui je vous avais donné
hier un conseil s'était elle apaise le
black out c'est à dire plus d'appels
plus de sms + relation de près ou de
loin avec fatou vous êtes dans une bulle
une bulle antifa tout c'que t'as pas
anti nerfs parce que c'est pour mieux
revenir
il n'est ce que vous savez je vous le
dis moi j'aime énormément fatou je sais
je sais qu'elle vous m
oui je sais qu'elle est sincère et je
vous le dis il ya un bon truc à retenir
de tout ça c'est que si fatou agi ainsi
ça veut dire qu'elle tient à vous et
siphat ou avait rien dit elle serait
passé autre chose ça veut dire qu'elle
ne vous aimez pas vraiment et ça c'est
déjà un très très bon point assez gentil
plus elle vous tej plus c'est une bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il s'en fout elle s'en
fout qu'on aille à gauche et à droite à
gauche
la fat ont été blessés oui pourquoi
parce qu'elle s'est dit je vois mon
homme ma chair mon sens bien sûr
embrasser une autre femme très
séduisante belles jeunes à forte
poitrine poitrine et est donc voila et
non pas tout cela grâce à cet épisode on
a vu les sentiments
et voilà là vous me touche et vous oui
mais vu qu'elle n'a pas d'organisation
avec son fusil
vu qu'elle n'a pas largué c'est non
c'est pas vrai dans les deux sens les
hommes n'ont pas la même sensibilité
effectif je vous le dis voilà fatou a
une sensibilité que je peux comprendre
voilà parce que on est on est pareil on
est balance tous les deux les n'ai
pratiquement le même jour à 10 jours
fatou et morin et fonctionnels comme ça
on est fusionnelle fusionnelle avec sa
wii menouni
[Applaudissements]
je verrai
m
j'ai ce matin donc oui les gens
attendent 10 heures où devait aller chez
le comptable avec fatou mais vous allez
être fier de moi je sais pas ce que j'ai
écouté les conseils de baba love
notre avis est recommandé le black out
oui l'émission hier c'est fini à 21h11
mais laisse aisément oui eh bien je n'ai
pas eu de contact avec fatto avant 21h30
à feu 19 minutes de black out of two
foot magazine ont l'habitude je
l'appelle tout de suite avant que j'ai
tenus denied attendent attendent
attendent et on ne sait pas si je me tue
à donner des conseils pour sa gelée
foutu en l'air et déjà me ruth je rends
mon tablier alors je suis en bbc signe
d'encouragement ont dit je les vois là
je lui ai envoyé un message et elle m'a
rappelé j'ai décroché
et alors on et fring zone rendez vous on
est allé aujourd'hui au rendez vous je
les rejoins aujourd'hui pour les rendez
vous à 13h30 et s'est déplacé avec moi
après allemand oui un petit bisou non
nous n'avons jour monsieur comme non non
et smack non non non franchement non
asmac non on est très non non un bijou
eskimos n'ont comme vous pouvez le
contacter elle était derrière là j'étais
dans la rue elle était à la vitrine de
l'institut donc j'ai fait comme ça pour
savoir si je pouvais venir chez elle à
diass et l'autre contre elle m'a dit oui
vous avez dormi ou ceux là dormi j'ai
dormi à côté d'eux à côté pas là c'est
pas voilà non non on entendre on est
amis on essaie friends hormis dans la
même maison
ce moment mais peut-être bientôt
fredzone oui on freine zone et on était
en fait une zone après j'ai envoyé un
message en disant merci de m'avoir
accompagné le m'a dit c'est un plaisir
les encouragements
c'est le black out d'accord national
black out dont vous faites faites ce que
je vous dis je veux le black out jusqu'à
dimanche soir va t on les reverra pas
bah oui ça ne marche pas de face on
essaye de ses noces tension cyril parce
que aussi ça peut être aussi mais oui
tiens là devant la france entière
pendant quatre jours gilles ne
s'occupera pas le terrain peut-être que
doit qui incarne ici
écoutez je vais vous dire non le coeur
d'une femme quand il est déjà occupé
difficile de l'ordre de dante quelqu'un
doute et je sais que le coeur de fatou
est occupé par jean et quand gilles vous
tapez au coeur de fatou il faut demander
cette enquête en vue qu'elle regarde
l'émission blackout sa part d'être une
vraie surprise que c'est pas c'est quoi
ça va le faire parce qu'il en a les
capacités à cacher c'est trop dur sinon
je suis essayée verra pas voilà les
vendredis mouture essayer ce soir je
sais were held in à paris elle dit pas
avec moi donc ce service est possible
d'aimer une amie à moi une amiens ac
bernard cottin à milan
[Applaudissements]
elle dit nous avons ces noms vous savez
où elle dit nous pas elle m'a dit reste
en artois moi j'irai quand même terrible
mais c'est quoi il ne s'est pas possible
c dans paris
oui j'irai comme si elle donne le nom du
restaurant c'est qu'elles aient droit
alors je veux quand même plus sympa chez
pizza haute
non mais oui non mais ce qu'ils aient
soutenu parce qu'imaginez il est tout
seul en bas de pendant la nuit et tout
de même à part ça parce qu est ce que tu
vas dormir chez cyril par exemple est-ce
qu'il est là s'il vous plaît je vais
vérité je pas non plus me récolter
toutes les tailles 4 mai à la maison
sans rigoler avec plaisir fatou reprend
le stoppeur conti les quatre jours non
mais franchement plaisir maintien
dorment ils font ça je sais
ouais c'est bien superonline famille on
sait bien il accélère mois avec plaisir
que j'accueillerai george takei
quant à trente pièces s'est facilement
d'aller croiser un toit sa seconde
n'avait même pas le croiser chez vous
plus tôt possible et j'ai eu beaucoup de